une production du studio
SF bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast
où on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités d' site animé par moi-même Dom
plant et P Quentin cette semaine un
grand plaisir de recevoir Rosalie
Bonenfant qu'on a déjà reçu sur le
Podcast il y a plusieurs années et qu'on
avait le goût de juste réinviter pour
discuter pour prendre des nouvelles ça
vraiment été seul podcast en fait moi
j'avais préparé plein d'affaires de de
trucs que je vais lui parler sur ses
projets sur sa carrière son ses ses
rôles à la télévision ses ses ses ses
contrats d'animation tout ça puis
finalement on a vraiment juste parlé
naturellement comme des amis parleraient
au à une soirée autour d'une table juste
prendre des nouvelles en fait un genre
de Live Update de comme ce qui s'est
passé
depuis depuis qu'on s'est vu en fait les
plusieurs années pu r c'est quelqu'un
que je croise de temps en temps dans des
shows musique grande fan de musique
québécoise qu'on se voit dans les
festivals puis tout puis c'est toujours
plaisant c'est vraiment une personne je
dis pas ça la légur c'est vraiment une
personne
exceptionnelle de de son intelligence de
sa sensibilité de son écoute de son
ouverture c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
rencontre quelqu'un comme ça c'est
vraiment c'est c'est c'est c'est rare
desis souvent dans les podcast c'est
plus une entrevue dans le sens que tu
sais on reçoit quelqu'un on pose des
questions puis finalement tout c
justement comme je disais toutes ces
questions là que je voulais lui poser
finalement ça c'est pas vraiment passé
parce que à nous relançait la balle puis
à nous poser des questions fait qu'on
s'est tout un peu ouvert dans ce podcast
là donc on a parlé de plein d'affaires
très personnel mais aussi des sujets
plus politiques comme l'indépendance du
Québec je suis revenu sur un texte
qu'elle avait écrit aussi sur O céit
fait dire qu'elle méritait pas de porter
un chandail d'un certain band puis
toutes les réflexions qui vont autour de
ça c'était vraiment c'était vraiment
intéressant c vraiment différent en fait
de de de de de de podcast ce qu'on fait
d'habitude ou ou plus informatif où
est-ce qu'on va inviter un expert là
c'était vraiment juste on s'assoit puis
on parle on ouvre notre cœur ça fait du
bien quand même on est ressorti de là
vraiment vraiment bien vraiment grandi
même fait que je remercie Rosalie on
l'aime beaucoup puis bonne écoute bon
podcast le podcast de cette semaine est
présenté par nos amis chez
manscate vous le savez on en parle
souvent parce que c'est des produits
qu'on utilise pour vrai les produits
manscape c'est une gamme de produits
complèt pour soit l'entretien capillaire
ou de poil capillaire c'est juste les
cheveux c'est aussi les poils pilosité
ces poils fait l'entretien capillaire et
piloseux et pil et de la pilosité
l'entretien des poils et des cheveux pas
vraiment des cheveux l'entretien des
poils et de la peau et de tout ce qui ce
qui entoure en fait l'homme fait que
c'est vraiment des produits dirigés pour
les hommes donc si vous avez des hommes
dans votre vie si vous êtes vous-même un
homme pu vous voulez lui offrir ces
cadeaux là ben c'est parfait et là
manscape on a déjà parlé du landm ça
fait tellement longtemps qu'on travaille
mancap qu'on a parlé du L 2.0 vous vous
en rappelez peut-être pas mais moi je
men rappelle très bien je les ai tout
chez nous on a parlé du L 3.0 qui
d'arriver à le 3.0 le 4.0 et là
retenez-moi avant que je tombe à bas de
ma chaise parce que c'est le landm 5.0
qu'est-ce qui est nouveau avec le Land
5.0 c'est qu'il y a maintenant deux
lames il y a la Lam avec la technologie
skin saave qui permet de clipper la
barbe mais vous savez quand qu'on clipe
la barbe ou évidemment les poils plus
bien il reste une petite repousse mais
là avec le Land 5.0 on tourne le land de
côté et on a la nouvelle
lame qui est
en aluminium et qui vient finir de façon
smooth la peauit qu'on vient vraiment se
mettre sa cuirette comme on dit puis
puis ça enlève complètement la petite
repousse qui reste avec la la classique
skin safe c'est un produit qui est
révolutionnaire puis qui fonctionne
vraiment bien évidemment moi c'est rare
que je suis ça cuirette au niveau de ma
face mais je suis à cuirette à d'autres
places puis croyez-moi ça fait le
travail fa utiliseer le code promo sans
filtre pour 20 % de Rabet et le chipping
gratuit sur n'importe quelle commande
chez mencate et ça inclut toute leur
gamme de produits un énorme coup de cœur
sur les les
parfums
premium c'est incroyable ce parfum là
moi je m'en mets puis je me fais
complimenter souvent fa allez acheter ce
que vous voulez mais sachez que ça c'est
un coup de cœur de pH alr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
salut [__] salut les gars ça va ça va
toi oui what's
up commencer un podcast what's up what's
j'adore que vous adressiez le WhatsApp
et salut [__] non c'est ça ben tu sais
ça fait partie de mon vocabulaire
courant maintenant c'est ça que je veux
dire non mais c'est parce qu'on a aussi
une longue amitié de 10 minutes avant le
podcast les gens peuvent pas
comprendreou exact une longue amitié qui
date en fait la dernière fois qu'on
s'est vu on dirait honnêtement ben pas
la dernière fois qu'on s'est vu la
dernière fois qu'on a fait un podcast
fait longtemps on dirait que ça fait une
vie oui au complet moi c'est
l'impression que j'ai tu l'impression
que tuas aussi moi aussi c'est dans le
temps que j'étais triste je pense ah
ouais il me semble céit dark là il me
semble c'était comme ça se peut que ça
soit C dark ça se peut ouais on est allé
loin quand même mais mais j'ai
l'impression que tu es une personne qui
va loin point fait que mais c'est parce
que je pense c'est le problème combien
de temps que ça ça fait 37 secondes j'ai
déjà parlé de thérapie let's go c'est ça
qui arrive quand tu fais comment ta
docteur docteur cl ex je veux dire tu
parles de toi les seuls contextes où je
parle de moi c'est en entrevue puis en
thérapie tout se m un peu sais des fois
je fais de la promo à docteur Clément
des fois je parle de mes dad chos en
podcast Clément tu dis si tu veux un 20
dollars de Rabet sur les kit cookit tu V
être un chef cookit docteur Clément
c'est tout moi je voulais je voulais
réécouter en fait en fait j'étais
j'étais sur le point de réécouter le
podcast pour comme savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on a parlé déjà j'éis comme ah je
suis pas sûr j'ai envie d'entendre
d'hommees de 2019 genre puis là j'ai
j'ai j'ai choké comme ça va me faire
trop mal ah ouais ça me fa trop mal de
m'entendre les 4 ans puis genre de de me
trouver con ou de fait que j'ai j'ai pas
j'ai pas osé fait que on va tout red
dire les mêmes en je pense je t'avais
dit que tu avais pas d'écoute en
plus c'est vra ah ouais tuas tu as ce
souvenir là mais j'ai souvenir t'avoir
dit quelque chose au contraire au
contraire j'ai hâte de voir j'avais pas
d'écout souviens t'avoir dit je sais pas
si cétait dans le podcast ou genre en
DMS mais je me souviens t'avoir dit tu
sais ce qui fait le talent d'un bon
animateur c'est vraiment d'être à laaffu
des réponses je sais pas pourquoi je t'
ça je sais pas pour qui je me prenais
mais je me rappelle je m'étais dit c'est
pas l'important c'est pas de briller
c'est de laisser c'est ouais mais
pourtant je veux pas je veux pas
peut-être que j'ai une extrêmement
mauvaise autocritique de moi-même puis
que je me connais très mal mais je me je
me considère comme quelqu'un qui plus
dans les coutes puis moins dans vouloir
prendre toute la place je te considère
aussi comme ça moi je me considère comme
quelqu'un qui se mal de ses
affaires notre perception de nousmême un
peu dans le fond mais c'est fou ça tu
faux juste penser à genre ok non j'y
avais écrit ça tu sais je sais pas moi
ça m'arrive souvent quand même de
repenser à des choses que j'ai dit ou
que j'ai fait ou est-ce que je fais m
what the fuck qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans ta tête puis là de savoir que la
qu' quelqu'un qui vit avec juste cette
interaction là de toi là mais les gens
ils pensent pas c'est juste le quand
qu'il vont y penser quand ton nom va
venir dans conversation quand quelqu'un
va parler de toi aut leur interaction
qui on eu c'est m' est venu dans mes DM
pu elle m'a dit que j'avais pas
d'écout c'est quoi le rapport mais
peut-êre je l'ai juste pensé puis
j'étais en train de me creuser ma tombe
moi je m'en serais souvenu peut-être tu
l' juste pensé tu viens de te tautouler
pour j'ai écouté vos derniers podcast et
j'ai adoré une belle sensibilité
beaucoup d'écoute les gars beaucoup
d'écout non mais le lapse de temps est
tellement court entre ce qu'on est puis
ce qu'on regrette avoir été ah par 4 ans
tu peux pas l'entendre moi je me dis si
j'ai vraiment dit ça le 4 ans peut-être
que je fais juste me flageler pour rien
mais je me dis je dirais jamais ça
aujourd'hui ta gueule Rosy de VOG 4 ans
tu sais qu'est-ce pourquoi mais même
au-delà de vlog 4 ans tu ce que tu viens
de dire c'est tellement r on le le gap
est tellement court que des fois je
pense à quelque chose j'ai dit ou je
pensais 2 mois puis je trouve ça fait
pas de sensis ah j'éis une autre
personne dans ce temp là j'ai grandi
j'ai tellement ché c'est ça avant mon
backpack
en avant je me trouve là c'est
perdu mais pourquoi tu étais triste en
ben je pense que j'étais encore sur des
vieux relents de comme oh c'est ma
personnalité d'être souffrante j'étais
pas encore complètement affranchie de ça
ok mais mais ça va là ça oui non ça a
l'air d'aller
l'ER définissait comme quelqu'un de
souffrant puis genre c'était comme c'est
comme la personnalité que tu avais
décidé d'adopter ouais moi j'avais
décidé que j'étais un personnage de Tim
Burton puis que ma vie cétait un très
très long soupire puisé je me ok oui
exact je me ben je peux avoir la
personnalité puis une unicité même si je
suis pas tout le temps sur le bord de Me
défenestrer cétait comme ou oui ça
rimait en plus on dirait moi je
reviendrais un peu vers la
tristesse je suis devenue David goud
ouais c'est ça ça va tellement mieux je
t'entendais un matin je montais de de
Québec puis j'ai écoutais plein de trucs
que que sur lesquels tu étais passé puis
je t'entendais à à avec Étienne boulet
oui puis tu parlais justement de de
cette cette période là où est-ce que tu
tu te cherchais pu tu disais finalement
dans le fond je suis une personne qui
réfléchit mais je suis capable de
réfléchir d'avoir des idées même quand
je suis heureuse ça c'est quand même un
bon shift là quand tu tu réalises ça
j'imagine mais oui c'est que j'avais
j'avais l'impression mon unicité
résidait seulement dans la souffrance
alors que ce qui m'appartient puis ce
qui on a tout quelque chose qui brille
en nous ouais ben pour moi j'ai réalisé
que c'était pas forcément défini par la
souffrance j'avais l'impression que la
souffrance est un gage d'intelligence je
comprends
j'empathtise donc j'ai mal alors que je
peux m'arrêter à je comprends
j'enbaptise et je canalise ça autrement
ouais ouais j'ai du fun quand même F
quand même ouais vous ça va bien les
gars oui ça va bien ça ça va bien ça
vatu mieux moi ça 4 ans ouais je pense
que ça va mieux que le 4 ans ouais
pourquoi à quelg hein
le 4 ans je pense que j'étais en ben
mettons si c'est comme c'est ça 2 je me
plus quel mois mais en tout cas j'étais
genre en récente séparation j'étais un
peu perdu j'étais un peu genre en
mode j'étais un peu Yolo dans le mauvais
sens du terme c'est pour ça tu écoutais
pas mon pauvreécoutais pasis
complètement troublé on des gens sans
savoir c'est quoi qui vivent ah ouais tu
étais en séparation puis ça a pris
combien de temps avant que tu tu te
sentes remis deessus mettant
complètement tu ve comment la
conversation comment la table a
tourner l'arrosur
arrosé
euh combien de temps que je me remette
de dus j'ai été c'est drôle parce qu'on
a parlé sur parle pas souvent mais j'en
ai parlé sur un podcast sur lequel on
est allé pas longtemps je pense que j'ai
été c'est un effet
Sonor vas-y
excuse-moi ben je vais réutiliser les
termes que j'utilise l'autre jour là
même si c'est pas gracieux là mais genre
je suis vraiment tombé comme sais
j'étais avec une fille pendant 5 ans
puis là c'est comme si après tu sa
finalement comme une bonne chunk de ma
vingtaine m puis après ça j'ai comme une
switch qui a flippé pu j'étais comme
faut que j'aille le plus de relations
sexuelles poss possiblebl avec le plus
de personnes poss possiblees fait que là
ça a comme j'ai ouais mais c'était comme
pas euh c'était pas euh sain je sais pas
comment dire là c'était comme un vide
que j'essayais de de combler de trouver
là mais ça ça finit par passer puis là
aujourd'hui là ça
fait j'ai j'ai une nouvelle blonde
excellent c'estoui ça va mieux pourquoi
oh je me suis saucée allaigrement les
quatre dernières années j'ai eu le plus
de relations sexuel avec le plus de
personnes possibles puis vraiment ça m'a
guéri là ça m'a ramené en fait au contra
tu m'a guéri par mais la passe dure
coïcide avec la passe ou est-ce que
c'est ça ton objectif non mais c'est ça
mais en fait c'est la passe dur le
symptôme de été genre d'essayer de
trouver ouais mais ça pour attendez
excusez-moi juste prendre un petit step
back sur ton expression des années 2000
je me suis trempé
excuse-moi jeux continuer non mais je
comprends tout à fait ce que tu veux
dire j'ai vécu cette période là aussi
puis c'est pas tant la génitalité là qui
est qui est attirante dans ce processus
là tant que tu sais quand moi aussi
j'étais 7 ans avec la même personne de
genre à 24 mais oui c'est fou ça fait
quand tu sors de ça de rencontrer des
gens à outrance ça fait en sorte que tu
découvres un peu à chaque fois parce que
quand tu laisses quelqu'un te rencontrer
la personne voit quelque chose en toi
toi tu peux mettre ça de l'avant ou pas
fa que ça te donne comme plein de petits
échantillons de quitter puis après ça tu
peux faire l'amalgame de tout ça puis OK
lui a vu ça en moi elle elle a vu ça en
moi fa je pense que ça peut t'aider à te
définir pour vrai non ça c'est vraiment
mieux dit que moi que
ça
oui ouais c'est ça tu sais puis juste
comme l'habitude d'avoir tout le temps
quelqu'un avec qui partager toutes tes
affaires pu depis avoir ça fait
que fait que oui je pense que
2023 sur mon x ça va bien le podcast va
bien le studio va bien la musique va
bien le la blonde est parfaite la vie
est belle fait que va
chier moi ouais toi 2019 2023 euh j'ai
fait le tour là j'ai fait genre all j'is
allé au fond j' allé au fond puis je
suis revenu puis là je je suis revenu
quand même ouais c'est un bon moment
bonne pass tu es revenu à combien de
pourcent pas sûr que je pense jeis
revenu différemment je suis pas sûr
c'est le pas sûr que tu peux revenir à
%
complètement je pense que je vais
traîner quand même longtemps des
affaires de
ça mais bon
ouais c'est ça fait que je suis revenu
différemment autrement disons puis toi
de 2019 à maintenant à part la tristesse
qui s qui sétait évadé mais tu es sur
ton X en ce moment mais moi je me suis
séparé aussi ouais euh je suis déménagé
en app part toute seule qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé j'avais tous deux hommes ou
pas encore je pense pas je pense pas non
décroché non non il y a eu des belles
affaire dans ma
carrière qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 4
ans qui m'a rendu compte J'ai commencé
une collection de taxidermie moi aussi
je suis sur mon x som tout la collection
de taxidermie c'est vraiment la chose
qui est le X
ouis j'ai ça me mais oui ça correspond à
tu sais mon espace il y a pas personne
qui qui juge comment je décore pas que
mon ex juget comment je décore mais tu
sais il y a cette idée là de
s'approprier un espace c'est un peu ça
que j'ai fait avec mon corps aussi quoi
ouais h je je je je va prendre ce que tu
viens de dire là parce que ça fait deux
fois juste dans la conversation qu'on
vient d'avoir ça fait deux fois que euh
tu aimais une pas une oui une théorie
mettons que ça paraît que tu as réfléchi
puis dans le short j'écoutais tantôt
justement tu allé je pense céit à tout
le monde sa ce que tu as fait avec l
Québec aussi puis ma ce que je me disais
c'est Chris cette fillel réfléchit donb
c'est ça exact je veux qu'on parle de ça
parce que tu arrivais des fois avec des
concepts sa je pense que c'était
euh amireux le concept que que tu as
amené à Al Québec ou est-ce que c'est
comm ok là non seulement tu as
intellectualisé tes relations amicales
et amoureuses mais en plus tu l'aura
donné un nom tu as développé ce concept
là dans ta tête puis tu es capable de de
l' mettre comme un philosophe le ferait
dans un essai non mais genre pour vrai
tu sais mett le concept de l'amireux de
niet sais genre puis je me disais ça
doit être des fois vraiment cool mais
souvent sûrement très lourd de réfléchir
comme ça bon premièrement je pense pas
que niet auraiti le con désamoureux là
trop fataliste pouridée que tu vois
juste là tu tu dis pourquoi n aurait pas
ai ça con connait les choses tuimis
pourquoi aurait pas aimi ça tuis tu
comprends ce que je veux dire mais
c'està dire que oui tu sa quoi dones des
amireux
ben j'ai j'ai je pense que j'ai
je t'en ai entendu parler il me semble
serait ton genre
[Applaudissements]
de si tu as le bras gauche en Gour ça
sent la TSE brûlé cling deux
fois comment comment reconnaître les
signes de stroke c'est gen tu arrête de
parler non mais ça déjà je pensais que
c'était mon néologisme même pas j'ai
réalisé il y avait plein d'autres gens
qui l'utilisaient aussi concept des
samireux c'est justement parce que quand
je me suis séparée j'ai réalisé que
j'aimais mes amis un peu de la même
façon qu'on aime des amoureux ou des
amoureuses
c'està-dire avec une grande tendresse
une grande consération avec une
affection aussi particulière tu sais
c'est c'est un amour pour moi l'amitié
qui est complet et qui est satisfaisant
qui est nourrissant qui nous élève comme
une relation de couple je comprends pas
pourquoi on valorise plus ça moi je me
suis tellement défini par mon couple
j'ai défini mon succès par le succès de
ce couple
làit l'idée d'avoir des amis reux c'est
comme de dire
ben il y a plusieurs personnes qui
peuvent combler des besoins que j'ai et
qui peuvent me satisfaire et
former une entité aimante et
bienveillante pour moi fa que ça c'est
une façon de de valoriser un petit peu
plus ses amitiés puis d'arrêter de les
voir comme quelque chose de monoliique
tu sais de se dire ok on est ami on peut
pas franchir cette cette barrière là tu
sais ça se peut dormir en cuillère avec
une amie juste parce que vous avez de la
tendresse ça se peut ça donner des
bisous juste parce qu'on s'aime ça se
peut je sais pas y a cette idée de
dynamiter les frontières du connu dans
l'amitié que je trouve super touchante h
ben c'est c'est c'est un concept qui
fait tout le sens du monde puis qui peut
paraître étranger à quelqu'un qui a
aucune idée de quoi tu parles ouais tu
sais parce que vous pas si longtemps moi
c'était quelque chose que que j'aurais
fait genre de quoi tu parles que je
rencontre un groupe d'amis qui était
plus dans cette ce vibe là parce
qu'avant mes relations d'amitié c'était
vraiment
traditionnellement amical toujours voulu
dormir en cuillè il jamais
accept chose envisager metton moi metton
pas ensemble pas nérement partager ta
tendresse mais juste ok mais qu le
concept de vivre metton de manière
poamoureuse metton ou ensemble tu par
non ensemble mett est-ce que vous avez
déjà j'ai eu des moments où vous avez
une conversation difficile puis ne
serait-ce que vous tenir les mains en
vous parlant non non là tu parles-tu de
nous deux spécifiquement de vous dans
vos amitiés en généraleok oh dans mais
tu sais ouais ben tu sais de se
permettre une proximité puis une
rencontte réelle dans ces amitiés
quelque chose qui est réservé au couple
normalement ex c'est ça c'est quelque
chose vous avez déjà vécu moi oui ouais
ouais ouais moi oui des des
conversations comme ça justement avec
avec ce ce groupe d'amis là o est-ce
qu'on on va genre puis on c'est ça
transcende vraiment l'espèce de de ligne
entre ce qu'on peut concevoir d'une
relation amoureuse puis amicale mainon
c'est vraiment ça le le flouou puis
euh puis c'est ça puis faut comme tu
faut comme tu déconstruis ces deux
concepts là en même temps puis il faut
aussi que s'il y a quelqu'un d'autre qui
rentre ex dans ta vie il faut aussi
c'est dur à accep c'est qu si toi dans
ta tête les concepts sont encore bien
construits c'est dans la tête de l'autre
personne mais oui ou oui oui pu ça puis
ça ça ça fait juste augmenter la
proximité amical dans le fond puis
l'estime de soi aussi tu sais de dire tu
as pas besoin d'être choisi par un seul
partenaire de te dire il y a des des
gens qui sont là qui t'aiment qui qui te
voit pour ce que tu es puis qu' a pas de
tu sais on parle souvent de l'amitié
gfille ou se commment Bigu puis on sait
pas trop oui mais il y en a un des deux
qui va aimer l'autre ben c'est pas ça le
but d'une amitié c'estaimer justement
moi je me dis s'il y a de l'amour c'est
pas un problème s'il y a du désir on
n'est pas obligé de Act puis si on
choisit de le faire c'est pas obligé de
définir ou de changer la relation sais
c'est ni comme exemple mais c mettons un
de mes meilleurs amis sort avec mon ami
tourne seul nous sommes tous amis C m'a
fréquemment vu tout nu quand on se
baigne dans un lac si mettons on se
baigne dans le lac machin machin il
vient me faire un calin par derrière il
y aura pas de comme ah ilessa toucher
mes seins oh mon dieu sa blonde
qu'est-ce qu'elle va penser parce c'est
juste c'est oh mon Dieu on se baigne
dans dans un lac on est trop bien on est
tellement tellement d'amour à se donner
ça vient pas compromettre le reste mant
fa c'est comme une façon ça sonne ben ép
très très libertin mais c'est surtout
une façon de vivre l'amour pour moi de
façon plus grandiose je trouve tu
m'aurais dit ça m quand j'étais à
l'université j'aurais dit oublie ça gen
cette fillel cette fillel oublie ça
genre
c'est genre va vivre dans une commune
dans les années 70 là tu sais vivement
ben c'est ça
volontier
amenez-moi tu sais mais mais là je
comprends exactement ce que tu veux dire
ouais ouais
ouais ça te permet je trouve aussi de
définir des frontières plus claires
quand tu rencontres un ou une partenaire
après parce que tu leur dis mais il y a
ces relations là dans ma vie ils sont là
puis ils vont rester là dans le fond
puis ils seront pas ça c'est une ça peut
être une pilule qui est difficile à
avaler mais de dire ils seront pas
inférieur à notre relation qu'on est en
train de bâtir il vaont être égal exact
ça va être la même chose exact tu va pas
plus prioriser puis encore une fois
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
qui qui peut qui peut faire peur à dire
à l'autre personne de dire je veux pas
prioriser notre relation au détriment de
ces relations là puis mais ça enlève
rien à notre relation à nous ça ça fait
juste démontrer que si je veux que notre
relation soit égale à celle-là ça veut
dire que c'est juste great je veux
m'investir exact c'est ça je veux
développer quelque chose de plus grand
que juste un couple puis même j'
entendais en dans dans Je juste on
dirait je continue la conversation que
tu as eu avec lor
euh on dirait que ça c'est deux l'idée
de de
de amireux et de couple non monogam oui
mais même on dirait que l'idée de amiux
et coupe monogam est même pas
conflictuel non absolument pas dans
cette vision là c'est ça que je trouve
qui est intéressant c'est pas genre ok
là avec mes amis je suis proche de même
mais ça veut dire dire que je suis
poamoureuse puis que je genre je couche
avec tout le monde c'est pas ça du tout
là tu saisc je pense pas que je Seris
cap ben je je sais pas si je serais
capable d'être polyamoureuse c'est pas
ce qui m'attire tu sais j'aime l'idée de
de bâtir une relation unique avec
quelqu'un mais en même temps je pense
pas que c'est je pense pas que c'est
propre à la monogamie de bâtir quelque
chose tu sais en en sillon avec
quelqu'un en fait pour moi c'est juste
une façon puis ça c'est vraiment le plus
important c'est ça que j'ai réalisé en
étant célibataire c'est que c'est une
façon de dire j'aurais pas besoin de toi
je me suffis puis moi c'est il y a rien
qu'on peut me dire qui me turn plus on
que j'ai pas besoin de toi sais je veux
que tu sois dans ma vie mais je veux pas
que quelqu'un dépende de moi moi je veux
pas être tributeur de quelqu'un j'ai
j'ai besoin d' tu sais je veux même pas
quelqu'un qui est accroché physiquement
après moi metton ouais je veux pas dans
un festival despider puis me sentir
comme pgier avec je veux juste je veux
mon espace si tu es capable de me triper
d de même tant mieux je risque de te
triper dessus aussi de cette façonl tu
sais le défi c'est de déconstruire on
dirais le tu sais toute forme de
possessivité là tu sais parce que c'est
pourquoi faut la déconstruire ben tu
sais parce que tu sais dans dans le la
tradition si on veut là tu sais mett mon
chum ma blonde je dire c'est c'est comme
il y a un pronom possessif là-dedans là
tu sais dans le sens que
puis HM h c'est l'importance des mots
c'est c'est c'est continue c'est bon que
continue creuse
creuse juste des notes éditorial pendant
le podcast genre ah ouais ouis ça c'est
un bon segment
vasy non mais tu sais puis je veux dire
originalement que dans dans la tradition
du mariage du couple whatever là tu sais
c'est comme c'est c'est mon mari ma ma
femme pas ma' partient mais dans le sens
que tu sais il y a cette ben je te
dirais que il y a quelques années les
femmes apparent cétait pas dans l'autre
sens
nement le problème mais là de puis puis
je veux dire dans sa perception aussi tu
sais d'être capable
tu sais dans dans dans le groupe d'amis
je veux dire de complètement même si tu
sais il y a cette ouverture là tu sa ça
je veux dire inévitablement ça se peut
que il y a des sentiments qui se
développent plus fort pour une personne
qui tu vois que cette personn là ben là
tu sa quand qu'elle donne à d'autres tu
sais être capable de de dissocier
complètement de genre je veux cette
personne là juste pour moi puis
j'aimerais ça tu sais que que c'est
c'est c'est pas une manre s faire je
sais pas si toi tu tu D avec ça ou si
comme tu as réussi à comme t'a frranchir
de toutes non mais ça c'est une idée
reçue moi j'ai l'impression qu'on on
assume que les gens qui s'aiment en
étant libre sont complètement dégagés de
possessivité puis de jalousie mais je
pense que ce qui change le plus c'est
qu'on arrête de juger la jalousie comme
étant une mauvaise émotion h TU SAIS
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
hiérarchisation là des sentiments de
dire ça c'est une bonne émotion à avoir
ça c'est une mauvaise ça faut pas la
vivre ça faut l'écarter du repè de la
main la FA avec la jalousie c'est qu'
est là que tu sois monogam que tu le
sois pas et là tu as beau tu sais tu as
beau dire nous on est monogam on s'aime
avec des œillires il y a personne
d'autre le sentiment existe pareil à
certain égard moi je pense que à
certains égards je pense qu'il faut
juste apprendre à laisser cette émotion
là nous transcender puis a pas la juger
tu sais ce qui fait qu'on reste pit avec
c'est quand on se juge pu on est commey
pourquoi je vis ça jeis tomb une merde
je suis insécure qu'est-ce qui
m'arrive quand on accepte que c'est ce
qu'on vit puis qu'on partage à notre
partenaire oh je trouve ça confrontant
tu t'en vas metton souper avec ton ex je
sais que vous avez tel affaire qui est
pas résolu machin machin je trouve ça
difficile j'ai besoin d'être assuré ou
j'ai besoin de temps pour computer tout
ça j'ai besoin de digérer ça de mon côté
quand tu arrives à juste te questionner
sur ce que tu
vis le laisser t'habiter puis le nommer
c'est pas vraiment un problème parce que
une fois que tu le nommes là tu réalises
que tu as pas besoin de t'attacher à ce
sentiment là pendant 2 he tu sais je
pense moi je pense que la la jalousie
peut être là il faut juste la laisser
moi j'ai longtemps pensé que la jalousie
c'était le pire sentiment au monde mais
c'est dur à tu toujours trouvé genre
c'est si tu mon thinking c'était si tu
vis ça c'est qu'il y a un problème dans
ta relation parce que soit tu le vis
parce que l'autre personne te fait
sentir insécure par ou tu te sens
insécure par rapport aux agissements de
l'autre personne ou tu te sens insécure
par rapport à toi-même h puis dans les
deux cas soit tu es pas en accord avec
les ajustement de l'autres personnes ou
soit tu as tu as un problème avec ton
estime de toi-même mais je pense plus
que je suis je pense plus que je le vois
comme ça maintenant non qu'est-ce qui a
changé non ce que tu viens de dire est
est est assez important où est-ce que je
fais un gros travail sur essayer de
comprendre quand que je me sens d'une
façon m puis d'essayer de faire
qu'est-ce qui est c'est quoi ça le c'est
quoi ça puis la seule la seule chose qui
te rend pas bien c'est que toi tu tu
choisis de pas être bien par rapport à
ce sentiment là que ce soit de l'ennui
de la peine de la de la la jalousie puis
maintenant je suis vraiment il y a
vraiment vraiment moins de choses qui
sont capables de m'atteindre parce que
je suis capable de faire c'est un
sentiment dans le fond une émotion imag
c'était moi qui disais ça voy on tu pas
un Plou de sentir ça Puy c'est juste une
émotion grow up a oui ben honnêtement
honnêtement un peu mais tu as envie que
je te dise c'est normal c'est correct tu
es pas une mauvaise personne c'est juste
normal puis comme tu vis ça puis amené
ça s'en aller puis genre la seule chose
qui te reste c'est comment tu t'es senti
par rapport à ça comment tu continues à
vouloir te sentir par rapport à ça puis
de pas fuir le sentiment aussi moi je
travaille beaucoup ça avec DECT cl de
pas Binger de pas tomber dans drogue
dans l'alcool de juste comme t'asseoir
avec le sentiment puis je pense qu'
accepter l'inconfort l'humain l'humain
cherche le confort c'est normal mais
d'accepter l'inconfort de se dire ah
présentement moi ça ça se manifeste là
ça me donne comme de la chair de poule
en dessous des cuisses là je comme ça
c'est vraiment pas le fun comme feeling
d'accepter c'est là de comme sit with it
on dirait que ça fait en sorte que ça
légitimise ton sentiment puis tu
acceptes que tu le vis puis c'est ça ça
ça devient pas un cancer 3 ans plus
tardou ouais exact c'est ça tu pas juste
le le pousser là comme le clip de
billber là qui fait juste TR long just
parler rafouler des trucs puis amener
pop il explose complètement sur le
livreur là et
c'est un sentiment tu sais je trouve la
distinction que tu faisais entre les
deux de dire il y a une situation qui
qui m'arrive qui me crée un inconfort
puis de le reconnaître d'essayer de
comprendre pourquoi puis d'essayer de
l'accepter c'est une chose mais tu sais
le deuxième type de jalousie de comme
j'ai je veux contrôler tout tout ce que
je peux contrôler puis là c'est là qu'il
y a une problématique ça moi je pense
que ça ça c'est plus
euh de l'ordre d'un trouble mental dans
le sens pas puis là je le dis pas de
façon connotée du tout là mais l' espèce
de désir de possessivité puis de vouloir
que quelque chose t'appartienne puis de
vouloir tout contrôler c'est là que ça
devient c'est comme quand que il y a il
y a
aucun il y a même pas de aucun stimuli
externe qui devrait te faire sentir dans
même tu fais juste te sentir dans
mêmeouais ouais mais là ça c'est quelque
chose à déconstruire que tu sois g ou
pas exa ou ça c'est un problème que tu
traînes avec toi là je pense plus mais
oui c'est des gens qui nous écoutent qui
sentent de même souvent genre il y a un
il y a un problème puis si vous êtes pas
supposé vous sentir comme ça vous êtes
pasposé tout le temps c'est ça
comprendre pourquoi ouis mais c'est sûr
C puisant à traîner à la longue comme
émotion mais pour les autres aussi pour
les autres aussi mais une bonne façon
moi tu sais sans vouloir me Muto
gaslighter puis comme enlever de la
valeur à ce que je vis des fois quand je
vis quelque chose de difficile je me dis
est-ce que je ressentirais la même
affaire si un ami qui me disait ça
mettons
j'ai un partenaire qui me dit ah j'ai
croisé mon ex avec un autre gars ça m'a
fait quelque chose laavir si ça vient me
pincer puis que ça risque de teinter ma
réponse initiale tu sais qui sera moins
dans l'intérêt dans la bienveillance
dans vouloir prendre soin de mon
partenaire j'essaie de me dire ok
mettons que je tu as une ami qui me dit
ça puis que je reçois pas ce qu'il me
dit comme une attaque personnelle comme
quelque chose qui qui entre en collision
avec mon ego qu'est-ce que je lui dirais
puis on dirait que même si c'est tu sais
des fois ça fait un peu fourni parce que
des fois c'est mécanique au début c'est
sûr que ton réflexe c'est de dire
tues-tu plus belle que moi qu'est-ce que
quoi tu veux revenir avec mais ce que je
répondrai à un ami c'est ah pourquoi tu
penses que ça t' fait quelque chose
est-ce que c'était le fait de l'avoir
heureuse avec quelqu'un d'autre est-ce
que c'est parce que toi te man quelque
chose machin machin de me ramener à ça
je me dis ok ben j'ai ça en moi tu sais
j'ai cette cette réflexion là par
rapport à un ami fait je suis capable de
l'appliquer à un partenaire c'est juste
que ça file un peu fi parce que c'est
pas on est pas conditionné à réagir
comme ça on est socialisé à à tout de
suite être dans confrontation fait je
pense que
ça ça peut donner l'air de se prendre
pour un autre mais une fois que tu
t'engages dans ce chemin là
naturellement tu dis ok ben non dans le
fond c'est qui je suis tu sais cette
douceur là c'est le chemin que j'ai
envie de choisir ultimement même si
c'est pas mon premier réflexe
nécessairement h c'est un peu un genre
de fake it till you make it là essaie de
truquer ta propre ton propre cerveau pu
tes propres sentiments
à vous êtes genre là vous êtes calmé
tout le on se cal tout le monde on prend
ça on prend du temps pour réfléchir à ce
qui vient de se passer même si c'est pas
instinctif parce que en fait il y a rien
de l'instinct j'imagine que tout est
tout est acquis là on tu sais c'est je
suis pas sûr c'est iné de se sentir
jaloux là tu penses je pense pas qu'on
est avec avec la jalousie en N autres je
pense pas que d'un point de vue
anthropologique genre faut être un peu
en compétition pour pour avoir la
femelle tu sais non mais M juste de
bébés là puis là il y en a un qui le
jouet l'autre le jouet tu sais a tout le
temps comme vouloir ce que l'autre a
vouloir avoir de quoi pour soi garder
les ressources tu sais je pense pas que
les bébés qui se chicanent pour un jouet
c'est c'est le même type de c'est plus
désir de quelque chose que tu as pas
metton là plus vouloir quelque chose que
tu as pas et non être jaloux de ce que
l'autre a tu sais c'est que le fait de
voir l'autre bébé avec son jouet c'est
peut-être juste te rappeler qu'il y a un
jouet qui existe que finalement là tu le
veux parce que tu vois que l'autre
personne l'a Raon après ça de la
jalousie honnêtement de vouloir ce que
les autres on j'ai j'ai comme
l'impression que on se le fait mettre
dans face fucking vite sens vraiment
vraiment vite c'est même une question
capitalisme tu sais ouais l'idée du
voisin gonflable de vouloir avoir ce que
ton voisin rapidement les premières
choses qu'on demande à nos parents c'est
un justement un jouet que Tommy a Tommy
class Tomy sal Tommy les plus beau
jouets la trampoline par une trampoline
c'est sûr que tu mis avait genre un
petit jeep motorisé est-ce que vous
aviez ça quand vous étiez D qui conduit
automatiquement AC les pied en dessous
oui avec les petites pédales ti un petit
je pied en dessous les pied un petit
little t là la petite voiture non non un
vrai truc motorisé qu'on branch c'est s
mis
laav mais oui c'est mais c'est c'est à
mode là mon neveu il y a ça là genre de
genre il y a son char il déjà son char
il y a 3 ans son conduit son char
dangereux bon faut les sortir des
routes
les bébés les personnes âgé là qui
voient plus là faut les sortir des des
voitures puis toi depuis que tu as
metton découvert ce je sais pas si c'est
une découverte tu toujours su ou depuis
que j'ai touché à la vérité en 1760 j'ai
découvert mais depuis que tu tu as
touché à la non monamie depuis que tu as
trouvé la fontaine de voistu c'est
encore possible de de de revenir en
arrière pas de revenir en arrière mais
de de encore t'entrevoir dans une
relation monogam ou comme une fois une
fois que tu es allé là si tu comme
est-ce que est-ce que c'est comme
quelque chose
queing puis une fois qu'on le trouve
comme c'est ça genre ben h c'est dur de
répondre à cette question là parce que
un couple ça se fait à deux là h mais
définitivement il y a quelque chose que
j'ai compris qui est comme un point de
non retour je sais que peu importe si je
m'engage dans une relation monogame ou
pas il y a plus de retour en arrière par
rapport à
se parler ouvertement être très
transparent sur ses envies ne pas avoir
à camoufler certaines conversations tu
sais moi je veux pouvoir parler de mes
ex à la personne que je date je veux
pouvoir parler de mes amis de gars je
veux pouvoir dire que les gens sont
beaux que je les aime je veux que la
personne puisse me parler de ses ex
aussi je veux qu'on ait des moments pour
se calibrer savoir ce qu'on veut fa ça
que que je sois monogame ou pas je veux
que ça reste je veux qu'il ait ce ce
moment là où on se dit ok on fait le
choix conscient de rentrer ensemble
c'est moi c'est un peu ça l'idée là
c'est de me dire tu vas voir tout ce
qu'il y a tout ce que le monde a à
t'offrir si tu me choisis encore c'est
une victoire tu sais je veux pas être
choisi par défaut
ultimement
mais c'est sûr que je vais essayer de
convaincre mes futur partenaire de
tenter la non monogamie moi je c'est
trop de pression là je veux pas combler
tous les besoins j'étais une fille
occupée j'ai des passion je bricole je
travaille genre je ve pas être la seule
que tu as envie de frencher là comme
j'ai besoin de j'ai besoin de suppléant
une fois de temps en
temps c'est bon ouais ouais
c'est
une question qui au final comme tu dis
t'appartient pas à 100 %. ben non tu
sais fait ça rend ça quand même
compliqué puis c'est c'est dur aussi
d'avoir cette conversation là puis là
peu
importe mon opinion ou ma ou ma relation
c'est dur d'avoir cette conversation là
sans que ça a l'air d'entrer dans dans
l'attaque d' attaquer notre relation h
de faire comme si ça se faisait au
détriment de son partage ouais ouais
c'est ça exact puis aussi pour les gens
qui nous écoutent puis qui qui c'est
comme il y a du monde qui nous écoute
qui font ça fait du sens parce que
essentiellement quand dans l'absolu oui
c'est genre ça fait tout le sens du
monde qui sont dans une relation ça fait
8 ans là il y a comme il y a comme pas
de façon de d'amener cette conversation
là sans que ce soit
genre notre relation est de la merde
c'est fini là tu sais parce que même
juste d'amener la suggestion ça peut
être vu comme une trahison en oui c'est
comme fait qu'on recommande aux gens
dans le fond d'écouter le podcast avec
leur partenairire dans le CH puis ça va
peut-être lancer la par pens de ça toi
les deux sont peut-être dans leur tête
en train de faire ça serait une bonne
idée mais que il juste pas amener le
truc à l'étape de plus qui est comme
d'avoir la discussion sais la discussion
ça peut être
c'est pas nécessairement une question de
libertinage ça peut être est-ce que je
peux avoir une soirée de plus pour faire
quelque chose qui m'appartient par
moi-même est-ce que je peux parler plus
ouvertement de C de ce est-ce qu'on peut
regarder tel contenu tu sais ça peut
être vraiment juste quelque chose qui
qui est propre à soi et à la carte là
c'est pas une question de d'aller
faociller tout ce qui bouge
nécessairement même que même que c'est
quasiment ça c'est quasiment un effet
secondaire du truc on dirait de comment
moi je le perçois de faire ok non dans
le F que tu veux c'est juste ta liberté
puis l'autre personne ça c'est un ajout
à ta vie à ta tu un ajout positif à ta
vie optimalement positif là c'est
négatif il des questions à se poser mais
essentiellement c'est la liberté dans le
fond l'idée de base pu c'est te chois
choisir ta liberté avant de choisir quoi
que ce soit d'autre c'est quelque chose
qui vous confronte vous quand vous
sentez que votre blonde est désirée ou
ou qu'elle très pailleur sans vous
qu'elle mettons elle r vient d'une
soirée pu dit j'ai connecté avec telle
personne goarou fille c'était malade ça
a été complètement en le vent comme
conversation est-ce que ça vient vous
chercher ou ou
pasant moi j'ai je pense pas que je
cette nature là là tu sais
de appelons ça soit jalouse ou envieuse
ou ça c'est jamais vraiment quelque
chose qui m'a tant habité
euh c'est moi ma blonde on est très tu
sais on a beaucoup avec ça genre genre
mettons t fille tu trou chaude puis
comme tu sais ça fait vraiment partie de
notre quotidien de comme de parler de
tout ça ouvertement puis que ça soit
comme vraiment normal puis fa il y a pas
de tabou à ce niveullà de comme
genre ça me demande si la trouve belle
non non pas tout il a juste toi ça c'est
pas bon là ça s y en a s'il y en a qui
nous écoutent qui se reconnaissent dans
dans ce que Dom vient de dire de faire
taableon dépose une question pu non non
là non non non non ça c'est pas bon mais
non mais moi c'est pour ça là que je
jeis parti d'un extrême à l'utre dans
mon long couple sais je voulais
tellement que mon ch sente que j'étais
loyale et tout peut-t j'avais peur aussi
par je viens sais tout le monde s'est
trompé dans ma famille allègrement que
je me disais en tout cas je disais tu
l'acteury je le trouve pas beau c'est
Ryan Gosling à l'out monde gen je ve pas
te tromper avec tout le monde le trouve
beau
làis genre tu me dis que tu le trouves
pas beau je te trouve quasiment
con moi j'avais l'impression que je
devais ça sais non je trouve pas que Ran
Gosling est beau non je me masturbe pas
il y avait quelque chose de comme je je
ne vis qu'avec toi alors qu'ultimement
tu as envie que ton partenaire a quelque
chose à te compter tu S ou c'est ça et
moi c'est d' parce que tu sais le
cheminement tu sais de tu sais ça fait
ça fait longtemps que tu es avec
quelqu'un puis d'essayie d'ouvrir la
conversation là-dessus parce que tu tu
as d'autres besoins d'autres envies moi
avec ça a fait le chemin inverse dans le
sens que ouais complètement dans le sens
que tu sais moi c'est justement c'est
quelque chose que je me suis demandé
CRIM est-ce que le le couple monogam me
convient pas est-ce que c'est comme un
autre modèle que je devrais checker puis
là just ma période dark j'étais comme
peut-être que c'est ça dans
ouais c'est ça peut-être que c'est ça
puis là quand j'ai rencontré ma blonde
sa là on parlait beaucoup puis tout
suite c'est allé dans les conversation
de cette nature là là tu sais puis
justement comment tu vois le couple
comment tu vois qu'est-ce sais toutes
les questions de la vie là tu sais puis
là c'est comme les deux on était comme
tu sais je pense que elle aussi s'est
posé ces questions là puis peut-être
dans d'autres relations à senté à
sentait plus prix ou je sais pas plus
qu' envie de comme de de de de de
d'ouvrir
ça deè date on é
[Rires]
commeent avant que ça soit même sérieux
avant qu'on se dis qu'on éta en relation
c'est comme les de é
comme puis là c'est comme si quand c'est
devenu sérieux de on a rechecké cette
question là tu sais comme est-ce que toi
tu es là ou tu es dessus comme puis les
deux on éit comme ah ben là je F pas
comme ça en ce moment puis toi non moi
je F comme juste j'ai envie comme ça
soit juste nous autres cool cool puis là
on a continué de même puis pour
l'instant c'est ça puis c'est tout le
temps chaque fois qu'on fait des checkup
de ça c'est comme ah ben en ce moment je
trouve ça cool d' même mais on verra
plus tard tu sais fait que c'est comme
j'ai l'impression c'est pas coulé dans
le béton non plus dans le sens que tu
sais c'est j'ai déjà pensé ça là en ce
moment c'est pas ça peut-être que plus
tard ça sera ça peutre que ça ser 15 ans
on va faire ch là on plus frencher pe
chilleur une FO pu ultimement c'est pas
ça qu'on veut d'une relation se laisser
de la place pour évoluer tu sais si pour
l'instant vous vous suffisez c'est
parfait puis après d'ouvrir ça ve pas
dire que c'est insuffisant mais tu sais
je suis pas en train de faire l'apologie
du couple ouvert comme quoi c'est mieux
là je trouve ça super beau d'entendre
puis je te crois que tu es bien je
trouve ça génial en fait je pense que tu
sais je faire l'apologie de dans le sens
qu'en ce moment
c'est monogam mais c'est 100 % libre
pareil parce que c'est 100 % par choix
c'est pas par par contrainte je me sens
pas obligé ou pris là-dedans c'est juste
c'est même parce que c'est ce que je
veux sais fre pas aujourd'hui c'est
super c'est pas vrai on je peux appeler
ma blonde je en
parler
podcast AC
toi par c'est comme faut avoir des
conversations tout le temps faire des
checkup c'est genre un texto pour
demander là
interrogation c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une blague là ça pas rapport
avec un appétit instaciable
histoire bref dans le fond c'est l est à
la liberté dans le fond à la liberté
dans la liberté non mais tu dans le sens
que c'est je crie ton nom
ouais c'est ça bref c'est ça c'est
trouver c'est trouver dans quoi qu'on se
sent libre puis euh puis bien et puis de
de faire ça dans le sens que que ce soit
un ou l'autre 100 % 100 % let's go let's
go on parles-tu de de Nirvana ah
parlons-en tuis d'autre chose à ajouter
sur ben non moi j'allais juste repartir
sur sur euh le fait que tu parce qu'on a
fait une énorme parenthèse sur ce
concept là mais je voulais qu'on parle
d'autres de réflexion global mais vas-y
parlons on est pas plus tard non Vy ben
ce que je voulais dire c'est euh moi
amener
j'ai décidé dans les dernières années de
juste vivre de comme juste genre
qu'est-ce que tu faisais de plus avant
je pensais à ce que j'étais en train de
faire je pensais à qu'est-ce qui pouvait
s'en venir je pensais à
euh ma relation mais en la procheant je
pensais tout le temps à genre des étapes
plus loin que juste aujourd'hui puis
j'ai réalisé que il y a la
vie change tellement vite les choses euh
tu peux pas prévoir rien qui se passe
demain mon fait j'ai juste décidé
d'arrêter de réfléchir euh comment ça se
passe pour toi globalement mon mais je
continue à penser à des affaires mais
décider de juste genre arrêter de de de
me poser cette question là justement par
rapport genre à une relation de faire
bon mais c'est quoi ça c'est juste ça
c'est ce que c'est genre la réponse
c'est ce que tu vis en ce moment c'est
ça l'affaire puis ça m'a amené une paix
d'esprit là de mais tu y arrives tu
parviens à réfléchir moins je parviens
je m'effce à réfléchir moins
quotidiennement puis des fois je fais
juste mettre des sons dans des
écouteurs au lieu de réfléchir je mets
des sons sur ma
passé depuis je réfléchis plus je
tellement heureux là depuis que j'ai
plus de voix
interne non je fais juste mettre des
sons dans mes écouteurs m des fois je
vais courir puis je cours quand même pas
mal dans vie
puis je m pas de podcast je mets pas
rien je fais juste mettre des sons pour
essayer de juste faire le
vide puis je mets la nuit je mets du
white noise pour me concentrer sur le
bruit ESS les bol tibétains les Sound B
ouis des gen de healing
frequenci ouais mais bref quand j'ai
fait ça ma vie a comme pris une bonne
tournure estce que j'ai arrêté de me
projeter pu de penser à qu'est-ce qui
s'en venait tu quelque chose avec lequel
tu struggles parce que clairement ça a
l'air de rouler quand même dans moi j'ai
pas réussi à arrêter de penser je me
suis fait presrire par exemple qui est
quand même un bon bon arrêter de penser
ouais mais c'est parce que dans le sens
où un man tu penses trop pour ton propre
bien là c'est pas une façon de dire
comme je suis tellement brillante moi je
réfléchis malgré moi il y a du monde qui
pense à des trucs C en
T surt que tu sais de tout
intellectualiser puis rationaliser ça
profite à personne des fois aussi là je
travaille bien gros sur sa je su
tellement bonne pour comme nommer des
concepts puis les visualiser puis make
it make
sense maintenant j'essaie de juste me
laisser descendre ça dans le corps tu
sais j'aimerais ça être capable de
ressentir autant que je parle et que je
réfléchis c'est surtout c'est ce
transfert là de la tête au ventre qui
est qui est plus complexe parce que
c'est tu sais c'est pas la pensée le
problème c'est la place
que mais oui je pense que c'est surtout
ça mais j'aspire pas à arrêter de penser
je pense que tu sais je sais pas comment
ça se manifeste pour toi page quand tu
dis je pense moins moi la la l'impulsion
est quand même là c'est juste que
j'essaie de me sortir de la loupe de me
dire ok je vois une porte je vais pas
entrer dedans parce que derrière il y a
un labyrinthe puis je vais être poné
dedans pendant 4h j' arrive pas tout le
temps mais tu sais c'est cette cette
encore une fois c'est très très très
rationnel et cérébral de me dire non va
pas là j'étais encore tu sais j'éis
encore un un peu sur le pilote
automatique là à ce niveau-là je
comprends distinction entre penser puis
ruminer aussi là tué gen penser tu sais
moi j'ai en fait j'ai fait l'exercice
inverse j'en parlais l'autre jour tu
sais j'ai moi j'étais
comme développé une dépendance à à des
vidéos genre de de dou qui parle de Star
Wars mettant quoi attends c'est une
blague tuas développé on répète une
dépendance à des vidéos de gars qui
parlent de St sont dépend
c'est ça ouais non mais genre Star Wars
ou puis là je par podcast parler pas
trop longtemps mais genre je comprend
pas la crise Desio
finalement dans le salon puis regarde
les vidéos Star
Wars okok ok mais Star Wars ou Game of
Thrones Lord of the
Rings genre d'analyse de gar qui
parle puis gen back story de tous les
personnages j'étais comme je me
bombardais à ça sais m qu avait un
silence fallait que je me mette ça genre
pour combler le silence je pouvais pas
être seul avec le silence OK puis là
mené j'tais arrivé à un point que là
j'étais comme là it's too much tu sais
fa que là il faut que je fasse de quoi
fait que j'ai fait c Turkey j lendemain
je d là tu as plus le droit d'écouter
des vidéos YouTube de gars qui parlent
de Star Wars puis là mais ça coïncide le
lendemain d'une journée où est-ce qu'on
est on était ici puis on est allé à le
fond sais
quand le fond pour comme des fois comm
moi c un highlight de comme mes derniers
mois là cette soirée
là pour lui il a touché le fond moi c
quand même c'est vra F une bonne soiré
il y avait aussi les dans le fond j'ai
recommencé à checker les vidéos de
gaming du jeu que je jouais quand
j'étais au secondaire et tu regardes
quelqu'un jouer tu regardes d'autres
monde jouer mais ça ça c'est c'est pas
si niché que ça là c'est une
grosse un gros public là c'est bon fait
que là c'est juste que ça serait plus le
fun si tu avais pas présentement une
vidéo YouTube sur tes genoux pendant
qu' tuas vraiment tu as vraiment une
mauvaise
écoute en deer tu es littéralement en
train d'écouter des doutes parler deob
one Kobi pendant qu'on fait un podcast
non
là c'est bon ok fa là ça c'était ça le
fond pour toi puis là il on est allé une
soirée moi puis lui super belle soirée
c'est je commencé à checker des vidéos
de de
Warcraft pu était comme on va jouer fait
là on est allé on a trouvé une place à
si j'allais dire amen on va faire du
C r gen lumière tisé genre un peu Corre
il y a des gars là dans le fond ordi
mais c'est quoi c'est comme une salle
pour am bref on a joué la soirée cétait
bien correct C FO mais là le lendemain
j'étais comme m'en faut plus il m'en
faut plus pu là j'étais comme non non
non non non ça ça peut
pas comme là gen tu es au y là sais tuas
croiser des chemins là c'est comme comm
ça tu prends le Dark Dark Side
ou ou tu te sors de de C enfire là fait
que là genre j'ai j'ai j'ai coupé Coly
mais ça pour dire mais tu es bon depuis
non non non mais jeer pas à me faire
lancer des fleurs
dans la c'est si ce que tu viens de dire
là wouh c'est un des plus beaux
accomplissements que j'ai entendu
j'étais full sincère sais des fois on se
trouve des petites béquilles sans dé
partir c'est dur j'étais vraiment
full mais ça ça partait du de du point
que j'ai moi j'ai fait le chemin inverse
de comme essayer de laisser plus de
place au silence puis justement je pense
que je me bombardais de de trucs de même
qui appartiennent à des mondes de de
fantaisie pour comme justement arrêter
de penser au monde réel puis au trucs
qui peuvent être stressant la vie puis
tout ce que j'ai à faire
puis puis je pensais que ça me faisait
du bien parce que sur le coup ça me ben
je pensais pas ces affaires là ça me
faisait du bien tu sais genre comme dans
l'immédiat ouais mais dans le fond je
faisais j'ai l'impression que je faisais
juste comme pêeter le problème en avant
parce que finalement les sources de
stress les trucs les problèmes à régler
puis exist encore il reste là une fois
que tu mets le vidéo de Star Wars à OFF
là ils sont encore là tu sais puis là
quand je me su rendis compte quand je
laissais une place au silence ben mon
cerveau se mettait en mode résolution de
problème un peu plus puis là genre ça
fait que j'arrivais quand même tu sais
plus vite je pense avec des des
solutions c'est
parce faut y penser à T tu sais dans le
sens où on veut pas ruminer mais sauf
que c'est ça mais il faut juste pas
tomber justement dans la loupe quand ça
devient comme la chose là tuarrêtes pas
de penser ça tobside puis là ça prend
plus de place plus de place plus de
place mais que il y a pas de d'issu de
solution en vue c'est là problème si ton
stress c'est faut je fasse la vaisselle
faut je fasse la vaisselle c'est
tellement stressant la cuisine est croté
peut-être que la solution c'est pas
fumer un BAT puis passer 2 heures sur
Youtube peut-être la solution c'est se
mettre dans l'actionire la
va je je comprends je comprends euh je
comprends ce que tu dis ben tu sais
c'est c'est un équilibre à trouver je
pense tu peux être un ça parce que moi
metton quand que des fois je faisais
Québec Monréal au complet en parlant à
gualopage pour essayer d'évoluer une
idée gualopage fictif là dans ma tête
moi j'étais
2h quand je réfléchis puis je le fais
puis je le faisais je fais quand je fais
la vaisselle des fois je fais ça ou je
le faisais j'essaie vraiment de MO fa
don des entrevues dans ta tête je fais
comme si j'étais à Tout le monde en
parle ah mon die je fais pareil avec je
fais comme ave ou je fais comme si
Guillaume posait une question comme si
guia voulait m'entendre moi parler de la
Kenel culture mettonsle fait que là
pendant fait que là moi je réfléchis à
voix haute en parlant de la Kenel
culture dans mon ch pendant 2h et demi
fait que ça faisait que j'étais capable
quand le monde me posait une vraie
question par rapport à ça j'avais une
opinion formée j'avais pensé déjà avant
sauf que je me
disais personne c'est quoi les chances
que que ça vienne sur le sujet que tu as
besoin de sortir un monologue de 40
minutes sur ce sujet précis là que ton
opinion soit tout à fait formée alors
que au final je m'encisse un peu d'avoir
pourquoi tu te juges tu sais dans le
sens où tu aurais parlé de ça avec
d'homme ça aurait été parfaitement
normal mais là vu que tu le disais à
guia le page fictif c'est comme ou c'est
non c'est juste que je pensais parce que
quand tu quand en tout cas je va parler
au jeu quand je tombais dans ce mode làà
c'était jamais euh pour des sujets qui
sont le fun ou qui sont pas des genrre
d'en jeux de société qui peuvent aller
chercher une FIB qui te met un peu soit
en tabarnac ou qui qui t'implique
beaucoup genre parler du trème lien mant
j'ai tellement parlé sais faut pas le
partir làdessus ça faut pas me partir
sur le trè lien j'ai tellement parlé à
moi-même du troisème lien comme genre
fuck tu en entends déjà tellement parler
à l'extérieur puis là tu en parles
toimême tu en parle un guolopage fictif
gen arrête tu fais une tête sur le sujet
c'est importantou mais je l'avais la
tête ça ça fais longtemps puis c'est là
tu rumines ben sa ça rumin dans le fond
c'est là tu fais tu parles tu parles tu
parles d'un sujet qui au final genre
soulève des pulsions puis à place de
juste comme faire e si on me demande mon
opinion à amener je la formerai en
parlant au pire j réfléchirai peut-être
quand je vais entendre une affaire ou
deux mais j'ai pas besoin de me faire
une opinion comme si j'allais écrire un
essai sur le troisème lien demain là tu
sais fait bref pour dire en même temps
c'est pas toi qui choisis c'était la
question de galopage c'est lui qui mène
son
entrevue crie dans ces DM je fais arrête
tes hos de Hot
seat capable que tu m'invites à Tout le
monde en parle je je connais pas Julien
Lacroix des questions
là on
une à voir avec Julien
laroix pourquoi tu demandes ça à
moi comme je faisais ça l'autre fois
avec hen justement puis mon ch rentré
dans le salon puis il me'a dit pourquoi
tu parles de souverainisme à de generis
pourois c'est c'est HL c'est çait tu es
vraiment bon en anglais es
comme tu parles de souverainisme à hen
Degen mais tu vois a l'indépendance du
Québec je parle d'indépendance je
parlais d'indépendance tellement souvent
alors que dans ma vie j'en parlais
jamais je parlais jamais d'indépendance
j'étais comme dans ma tête tout le monde
était tout le monde savait mon opinion
tellement claire sur l'indépendance du
Québec pas qui est au courant là c'est
quoi ton opinion sur l'indépendance du
Kébec ah moi j' à guerre pour
l'indépendance Dubec ah ouais ben ça
viendra jamais aux armes ça sera pas une
décision que j'aurais à prendre fait que
ça fait beau idéalistement de dire
j'irai à guerre pour l'indépendance du
Québec mais ouais c'est tellement pas un
enjeu qui est à la mode je trouve dans
notre génération radical un radical B
oui dans le fond ou oui oui parce
que j'ai vraiment
comme je pense que c'est tellement
nécessaire
que je suis plus je pense que je serais
plus radical activiste indépendantiste
que bien des sujets d'activisme pour
lesquels je
pourraisal comme j Pariso était radical
avec son vote ethnique mettons ou
radical Radic radical à quel point
radical dans le sens où je ferais si
mettons il y avait si le Parti québécois
rentre au pouvoir pu il y a un
référendum qui s'en ligne probablement
que ma plateforme deviendrait une
plateforme d'activiste indépendantiste V
provincial on a droit de parler de ça on
peut parler de ça j'ai voté pour le
Parti québécois aux dernières élections
c'est vrai ouais ouais tu aimerais pas
ça avoir GND à tête de ton pays tout à
fait j'aimerais tout à fait avoir
Gabriel Lau du bois à la tête de mon
pays mais je pense que je prendrai
Gabriel Nau du bois pas dans Québec
solidaire moi ce serait ça mon ce serait
ça ouais parce que mais là on peut
parler parlons politique parlons
politique parce que euh j'ai évidemment
Gabri Dubois je trouve qu' qui est un
leader qui serait exemplaire je pense
qu'il est super bon je pense qu'il y a
des idées qui sont vraiment pertinentes
puis euh super intéressante je pense que
pour l'idée un pays vers l'indépendance
ça prend un parti qui a de la cohésion
puis j'ai pas l'impression que Québec
solidaire en ce moment c'est ce qui
dégage nécessairement sur toutes les
idées fait je vais prioriser pu cétait
ça ma décision au dernières élections je
priorise l'indépendance du Québec à au
partis qui vaont le faire dans le fond
hm je comprends fait je priorise le
parti qui aurait le plus de chance de
mener à l'indépendance versus le parti
qui une fois qu'on est indépendant ben
on décidera quelle partie qu'on veut
qu'Il nous guide dans le fond on
décidera si le Québec va être un pays de
droite ou de gauche une fois
l'indépendance fait pu tu penses qu'on
va convaincre les Québécois de faire
l'indépendance puis qu'après ça on va
les convaincre de déloger le parti qui
est à tête qui lu aura r dononné
l'indépendance pas dans pas en quelques
années dans le sens éventuellement comme
dans tout les pays il va un gouvernement
qui va devenir de droite un gouvernement
de gauche quelques années plus tard puis
ça va être la même bascule que dans
n'importe quel pays au Canada on le voit
vraiment bien le conservateur libéraux
conservateurs libéraux depuis des années
mon pauvre je pense c'est plus la montée
de la droite que d'autres choses qui est
à prévoir là en ce moment oui après ça
ça va être un retour de la gauche
probablement de voir ce que va en penser
en tout cas ouais à suivre
tu mais ouais ça c'est mon opinion sur
sur les élections après ça que ça va
être comm ça aux prochaines élections
provinciales à suivre même temp game d'ê
mouillé là il y en a peu qui qui se
mouill sur l'indépendance du Québec
c'est tellement un sujet mais toi ta
position quand tu parles à tu es pour ou
contre l'indépendance du Québec euh
mais ça devrait pas c'est un sujet
délicat ça devrait pas être un sujet si
épineux que ça parlerépend sucite les
passionsou je comprends je comprends
mais tu
sais moi je suis capable d'en parler
sans jamais devenir sans jamais
développer d'animosité ou de ou
de de me braquer dans ma position avec
les gens là non mais je veux dire
l'Internet est une place sur laquelle on
bien plus de contrôle ça faut pas que tu
faut pas que tu regardes ça faut que tu
arrêtes de regarder internet faut pas
que tu regardes les commentaires les tu
sais je veux dire il y a peut-être du
monde qui vont qui vont ça me surprendra
qu'il y a du monde qui bâche ce que je
viens de dire là tu es plus pareil toi
depuis tu es un ami tu penses plus tu
utilises plus internet tu es tellement Z
de d'eau dans ma toilette c'est les
toilettes sèches maintenant à l'arrière
de chez nous les toilettes au composte
c'est bon ça mais si référendum était
fait par les audisturs sans fait le
podcast on serait un d'après moi on
serait un pay non mais fait le sondage
sur la page Instagram pu c'était genre
56 % oui quelque chose comme ça mais
évidemment c'est pas un échantillon
scientifique là mais quand même
intéressant ouais ben c'est sûr que si
les c'est sûr que si les les animateurs
sont indépendantistes les chances sont
que les Pens traverse un petit peu
jusque ou que le filtre se fasse dans
nos
audistor je pense que tu sais moi c'est
une question qui m'a tout le temps
intéressé grande fan DESCO que j'ai tout
le temps été comme très très près de
cette partisanerie là mes parents
étaient souverainiste aussi mais c'est
sûr que là il y a des enjeux qui me
rejoignent plus aujourd'hui puis ce que
je trouve un peu tendancieux c'est
que ça peut pas pour moi être une
solution au fait qu'on a déà appris à
vivre ensemble je sais pas si on a déjà
appris à vivre ensemble mais tu sais par
là c'est le Québec mais après ce serait
facile d'être dans not petite chambre
avecc puis dire tu sais quoi actually
Montréal serait un meilleur pays tu sais
parce qu'on aurait pas les opinions d'un
tel puis de parce que Mané on peut pas
se faire 42 micro pays mais je pense
aussi que je pense aussi que c'est c'est
un petit rêve que qui est un peu sa
tablette pour moi mais s'il y a un
projet qui revient c'est ça faire moi
c'est moi c'est c'est ça que je pense
parce que quand le monde dis c'est mort
cette idé là je met tout le temps avant
de déclarer ce mort à 100 % ramenons la
question pour de vrai parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup de monde
pour qui s'est endormi mais qui va
ramener la question ça prend quelqu'un
de passionné ça prend quelqu'un qui
porte ça j'ai l'impression qu'on a pas
ce genre de leader pr Mo jeis pas prêt à
dire que que Paul Saint-Pierre plondon
c'est pas la bonne personne pour faire
ça je pense pspp va nous donner un pays
je sais pas si c'est lui qui va le faire
mais je pense que c'est la bonne
personne pour ramener la question ah
ouais ouais mais tu sais c'est ce que
les sondages nous disent aussi
essentiellement ruba Gazal qu'on a eu
ici qui se présente par une très bonne
personne pour ramener la question tout à
fait tu sais puis justement je trouve
que c'est le fun que la question
souverain souverainiste est amené par
des nouveaux nouvell VO type de visage m
Nau nouveau type de dans le sens que tu
sais c'est pas je pense que il y a une
certaine vision de du souverénisme que
c'est comme uneaffaire des comme des
blancs francophones mettant puis que tu
sais c'est c'est ça peut plus être ça en
2023 c'est une des chose qui nuit le
plus au mouvement souverraainistme j'ai
l'impression c'est cette perception là
de ce que ça de ce que c'est puis de ce
aussi de ce que c'est réellement pour
certaines personnes là tu sais il y a
certaines personnes qui veulent
l'indépendance du Québec euh pour ces
raisonsl ouais ouais parce que quand on
dit le peuple québécois pour moi le
peuple québécois c'est nous trois mais
c'est aussi ceux qui veulent pas
d'enseignant voiler ouaisou on fait un
pays avec ça je sais pas je sais dans
sens où ouis mais ça je veux dire le
Québec de la caque pour moi c'est pas un
Québec qui ressemble à un futur pays
mettons h hm je comprends je comprends
mais tu sais c'est comme un pays c'est
c'est c'est c'est toujours multiple
c'est
touourers toujours div il a quand même
quelque chose que je pense
qui qui nous unit en dessous de comme je
pense quand même que la plupart des gens
qui partent partage ce territoire là on
qu même donateur commun ben tu sais il y
a la langue puis je dire même ceux qui
parlent pas tu sais je veux dire ils
font quand même évidemment partie de de
de ce tout là puis je pense que je sais
pas j'ai quand même l'impression que
historiquement culturellement on a
quelque chose qui nous distingue tu sais
puis que ça ça va même si c'est en
constante évolution c'est pas de dire
genre c'est le c'est c'est pas le le
Québec de de de Félix leclaement c'est
le Québec de 2023 avec tu sais tout ce
que c'est devenu en même temps c'est
très romantique de faire comme si on
avait le temps de se rendre un troème
référendum avant que la fin du monde
nous fauche tous c'est ça exact c'est
très optimiste c'est très optimiste de
penser à ça on devrait au lieu
effectivement penser à qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire quand que tout le monde va
venir au Québec parce que c'est un arche
qu'on doit se construire place place à
VI tout à fait ouais ouais mais mais non
c'est mais tu vois c'est bien que tu en
a parlé dans la là tu arrivé ici puis là
tu avais tu avais une opinion formée tu
étais prêt en parler sur un podcast
c'est quand même pratique quand tuas un
podcast de comme faire ça dans ouais
ouais peut-être il y a une limite par
exemple ouais
c'est juste pour rebondir parce que ça
c'est c'est un j'aime j'aime ça cette
idé là de parce que tu mentionnes les
personnes qui veulent pas d'enseignant
de voilé mon
puis tous les pays ont plusieurs
personnes tous les pays ont des gens
complètement débiles comme ont des gens
super radieux puis je pense que ce qui
fait vraiment un pays pu ce qui fait une
nation c'est ce qui est comme Dom dit en
dessous de tout ça ce qui rassemble tout
ce monde là puis on va si on fait un
pays et ça va être il va avir des des
colons c'est sûr parce qu'il y en a dans
toutes les pays tu sais il y en a au
Canada en ce moment on ceux qui veulent
pas LC en voiler je te dirais que c'est
nos ancêtres les colons la part d're
nous oui effectivement effectivement
mais plus des cave disons je voulais
dire cave ou voilà ouais en tout cas
bref c'est ça FA CRIM je pensais pas
parler d'indépendance j'ai bien fait de
me préparer tu as raison j'ai bien fait
de me préparer avec gu ou sais en tout
cas puis je veux dire dans le cas des
caves aussi des
fois des fois avec un commentaire
Facebook euh une personne a de l'air
cissement en cave metton mais genre
finalement finalement la personne c'est
une personne juste qui a qui qui qui qui
qui voit le monde à travers
un spectre différent du tien qui vit
dans qui vit qui a pas les mêmes
réalités qui a pas les mêmes
connaissances peut-être puis genre quand
tu parles à cette personne dans le fond
cette personnelà c'est ta tante ta
grand-mère tu sais c'est comme c'est du
monde qui nous entour tous là c'est
juste
que c'est c'est quand qu'on se parle en
face on se rend compte que on est plus
en commun metton est-ce que vous
abdiquez des fois mettons votre tante
votre grand-mère votre oncle tient des
propos qui ont pas de bon sens est-ce
que des fois est-ce que vous allez
essayer d'engager la conversation puis
de la faité ou juste moi jamais choisir
vos combats non jamais jamais parce que
pour pourquoi vous pensez que c'est
peine perdue c'est parce que les
fonctions familiales oh sont tellement
rares
et au
final on peu d'impact dans ma vie tous
les jours h que juge pas que ça vaut la
peine de les les compromettre de les
compromettre puis de les salir de
quelque chose qui au final euh je veux
dire va pas changer c'est une façon de
dire cette personne là m'est imposée je
vais choisir la paix on va on va vivre
ensemble en harmonie au même titre que
s'il fallait qu'à chaque fois que je
vais dans un souper je m'insurge parce
qu'il de la viande sur à table ça
j'aurais pu de souper ah ouais tu manges
pas de viande non V c'est vrai on fait
une émission ensemble première fois
qu'on sétait vé sur ça fait tu sais je
peux pas faire ça je peux juste pas
faire ça ça va ruiner des amitiés ça va
puis ces chosesl sont sont plus
importantes à mes yeux ça c'est la
sagesse d'un végan aussi là pas le choix
é tu deviens fou là tu sais au début je
le faisais plus puisé c'est comme Mme
genre c'est cave là ce que tu fais là
c'est ça changera rien tu sais puis au
contraire ça va peut-être même braquer
les gens dans leur position puis ça
m'est arrivé tu sais dans des just dans
des dans des soirées
familiales d'entendre quelque chose qui
fait aucun fucking sens selon ma
perception du gars qui a vécu 5 ans à
Montréal qui est un peu W qui est un peu
de gauche de faire non genre je veux pas
adresser ça c'est ça h toi tu tu tu le
mentionnes dus soulèves ça ou tu es
aussi capable de par tu es quelqu'un qui
est quand même vocal et engager sur
plein plein d'enjeux ma face surtout
c'est ma face à retenir
là c'est un enjeu ah ouais hein mais non
non j'essaie de j'essaie de en fait ça
dépend avec qui mettons avec ma mère
pour moi c'est super important qu'on se
confronte puis j'essaie avec l'âge de le
faire plus calmement tu sais justement
dans une approche plus on va se prendre
les mains puis je vais t'expliquer
doucement c'est quoi mon point mais il y
a des fois où tu sais mettons sur
facebook là ça j'ai appris ça de patelag
d'apprendre à bloquer bloquer bloquer
bloquer parce que mé c'est pas
nécessaire tu sais je m'stinais avec un
gars metton dernièrement qui me disait
je faisais la promotion d'un show deux
hommes où on avait
euh on avait genre Safia Nolin on
parlait de sexe c'était comme un show
très très très très woke puis là j'ai
juste partagé en story sex Safia et ok
Sophie va capoter puis là il y a un gars
qui m'écrit tu es une journaliste tu as
pas le droit de dire ça tu es payé par
la télé d'État premièrement pas
journaliste deuxièmement mon compte
Instagram est pas financé par l'État ça
mant au lieu de m'obsiner avec lui puis
lui dire ben non j'ai le droit de le
dire c'est un commentaire éditorial
machin machin je l'ai bloqué parce peux
pas gagner oui c'est c'est ça je m'en
saque quelqu'un près de moi je vais
essayer à tout le monde d'ouvrir la
conversation puis de pas de pas
abandonner mon de pas me dire oh ça sert
à rien les mots là ça sert jamais à rien
ça sert tout le temps quelque chose puis
même si c'est juste semé une petite
petite pe petite graine peut-être que
quelqu'un d'autre va passer après toi 3
mois plus tard suggère une idée
similaire puis la personne va faire des
liens puis dire ok c'est pas juste ma
petite woke de fille qui pense de même
tu sais c'est quelque chose qui
s'installe puis je pense que c'est en en
soupoudrant nos convictions à gauche et
à droite que finalement on finit par que
le risque de de ruiner cette interaction
là en vaut la chandelle essentiellement
c'est ça que tu ben je veux dire si ma
mère me dirite parce qu'on pense pas la
même affaire sur notre relation pense
pas à ta mère je pense plus des des
proches qui sont plus ou moins proches
si on en même temps c'est ça c'est que
moi mettons quelqu'un qui qui est en
désaccord avec moi sur des valeurs
fondamentales j'ai pas envie que ce soit
une personne proche si si un proche
quelqu'un dans ma famille passe un
commentaire transphobe je vais pas
prioriser notre relation au détriment de
toutes les trans qui perdent la vie
littéralement pour ma' à cause que je
passe un commentaire tant mieux mais si
tu es pas capable d'arrêter de passer ce
commentaire là h tu vas te passer de ma
présence aussi parce moi je veux pas
être exposé à ça oui moi je pense en
fait c'est ça la distinction je pense
que je vais intervenir dans des cas que
c'est des personnes que que j'aime
vraiment puis que je veux sa avoir
proche dans ma vie puis que c'est pas
qu' va le faire puis là c'est comme tu
sais je veux m'entendre avec cette
personne là tu sais je veux qu'on qu'on
se comprennent puis qu'on aille sa des
genes de bases des valeurs communes tu
sais puis si on en a pas je veux dire au
final ok mais genre sais justement des
situations de tuas quelque part il y a
l'ami d'un ami qui est là qui dit
quelque chose qui a pas de bon sens tu
sais souvent je un peu comme toi une
coup je va faire sa c'est
comme ce combat là ne m'appartient pas s
qu'on parle de trop loin je juste faire
genre puis genre rien dire parce que je
sais je juste conter une anecdote qui
est arrivée à Dom puis moi OK puis je ve
pas nommer de nom parce que ça c'est
vraiment pas ça l'objectif du truc mais
on est dans une dans un gen genre de
soirée dans un parc puis là il y a un
gars qu'on qu'on connaît un peu de nom
seulement qu'est-ce que tu vas compter
puis là il y a ses amis de filles qui
sont là tu sais là on a une discussion
sur genre l'importance il y a une fille
qui mentionne que son chum il a dit
genre que au début de la relation il a
mentionné que sa carrière c'était pour
lui la chose la plus importante pour
l'instant il était pas prêt à mettre ça
secondaire c'est une super conversation
super honnête puis là là on se met à
parler un peu puis là il y a une fille
qui aimait genre une opinion comme
vraiment
legit là je me rappelle plus c'était
quoi son point là le gars qu'on
connaissait limite il a juste fait et ça
là c'est ton opinion de femme OK puis là
il a juste changé puis là Mo on s'est
regardé puis là là genre dans contact il
y avait qu'est-ce qu'on fait là parce
que là genre vous
avec on peut des fois dans un parc on
peut intervenir ou on peut juste comme
parce que on le connaissait pas dans ça
la fille à qui a dit ça cétait une de
ses amis de fill tuit comme trois filles
qui étaaient amis puis là les autres il
ont comme un peu donné un petit peu de
merde par rapport à ce qu' venit de dire
fait que là on a comme fait bon ok ça
c'est on n'embarquera pas là-dedans
parce qu'on s'en va dans 15 minutes puis
genre mais cétait c'était comme ok là
est-ce que genre la question est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on agit làdessus là mais
mon ami proche ça pu je fais voy tu
viens dire ça mais c'est la différence
entre l'amour puis l'intérêt tu sais je
pense que si un
conflit un conflit disparaît sans
résolution c'est pas de l'amour je pense
que tu fais juste comme enterer ça puis
bâtir là-dessus mais je pense qu'en
amour tu veux en amour en amitié en
famille tu veux pas de ça parce que tu
veux pas que cet écueil là fasse un
petit une peti carille dans
relation desis tu rcontes du monde puis
t affair puis tu te confrontes pas mais
tu fais ah cette personnel ne
deviendrait probablement pas un ami
proche parce que clairement il y a des
il y a des différent mettons puis
quelqu'un qui dit ça ben ça ça
connectera pas plus que ça sais ouais
exact ce qui me fait on il nous reste
pas longtemps là ilta 23 je viens de
regarder
subtilement tu voulais tu rapper quelque
chose ben j'allais faire un Segway vers
Nirvana mais là on aura pas le temps d'
tu rapper
Nirvana si je veux tu Rapp faire un rap
ouais sur
N non mais c'est parce que tu sais on
parlait aussi de de de de répondre à des
gens qui nous écrivent des commentaires
puis là ça m'a fait penser à histoire
parce que j'ai lu ton papier pipi
territoriaux puis j'ai trouvé ça bien
intéressant puis tu en 2 minutes nous
expliquer qu'est-ce qui s'est passé puis
comment tu as répondu puis après ça
autes on réagit en 30 secondes pu après
ça on fait que là on tombe en format
radio là ouaisok le PO qui s'en vient ce
qui s'est passé il y a il y a un
réalisateur qui m'écrit un manig poste
une story dans laquelle je porte un
chandail de Nirvana qu'une styliste m'a
trouvé un chandail très confortable je
connais quelques tones de Nirvana j'ai
pas de tato de Nirvana mais je peux sais
je peux reconnaître quand c'est je peux
parler de combi d' un peu tu sais jeis
pas complètement
néophite puis là le gars m'écrit lol
name three songs le classique h là moi
j'aié tes trois songs j'en ai si songs
j'en ai neuf song si tu veux mais
pourquoi toi tu décides que genre tu
tuas tu as le monopole des trip NV qu'on
parle de ça ah ouais ça vient de
chercher ça si euh continue on y revient
en tout cas puis là j'explique au GS
voyons pourquoi c'est quoi cette
présomption que je connais pas quelque
chose genre toi tu penses que tu es le
seul attpé sur le groupe le plus
populaire au monde genre voyons puis là
il me répond my god je pensais pas que
tu allais te vexer là je lu prête un ton
pas Tex mais clairement il parle comme
ça à lire émoji yeux d' pu je gen ah
quelle PL puis là il me Gasse en me
faisant sentir que je réagis trop fort
parce que je veux pas y répondre puis là
j'ai dit tu veux je te donne TR toures
de Nirvana puis comme mais trop tard tu
as le temps de googler je comme voyons
c'est c'est insignifiant genre c'est pas
grave il y a le droit de présumer que je
connais pas ça mais pourquoi toi tu
assumes que tu connais quelque chose que
moi je connais pas parce que j'étais une
faceille parce que je comprenais pas
d'où ça venait puis là j'ai écrit un
papier dans la presse là-dessus les
pipis territoriaux les les gars qui ont
envie qu'un band leur appartienne comme
si le fait qu'une fille tripe dessus ça
altérait le coolness du band fa que j'ai
été comme bien insulté de ça CIT une
réflexion sur CHR faut aimer combien de
tes d'un band pour pouvoir porter un ch
et surtout est-ce que les filles peuvent
arrêter d'avoir à justifier ce qu'elles
porte en tout temps je porterai un
décolleté j'aurais à me justifier je
porterai un col roulé ce serait la même
chose là je porte un chandail oversiz
c'est pas correct encore fait que c'est
un peu ça le point là ouis ouais c'est
un peu un voyons voyons toi tu un
chandail davidine je suis pas mal sûr
queétait pas un mot mon chum comme on en
revient tu sais c'était ça le propos
mais c'est intéressant puis tu sais je
je lisais je te lisais puis je trouvais
que tous tes arguments faisaient le le
le plus grand sens du monde pururiste
hein mais tu sais évidemment tout le
monde peut s'habiller comme il veut j'ai
ch Davidson j'amais fait de motos de ma
vie l'exemple était vraiment bien bien
choisi mais c'est drôle parce qu'on a
déjà un quand Mme on a déjà un peu été
cette personn là pas lol écrire au monde
dans LEM mais surtout lol tu es obligé
d'être arrog Mme sais je v évidemment
jamais commenter la photo quel de
quelqu'un puis écrire à quelqu'un pour
lu donner de la merde sur le chandil de
Ben qui décidé de mettre mais on é une
fois on é invité un podcast de Ki je
c'est qui je sais pas si écoute encore
le podcast parce que ça fait deux fois
qu'on làdessus mais run joke avec lui
aussi c'est ça puis là c'est devenu une
joke mais il y avait un gilet gun and
roses puis là j puis puis là quelqu'un
accuse le fait qu' get g Ros gen en jant
sa puis ton get puis comme quoi de quoi
genre non puis
là ben g Ros ah je sais pas puis là j'
comme g roses non tu connais sweet child
of mind tuas tuas déjà entendu ça je
chante la Tun ça me dit rien fait là
j'étais comme évidemment il a vu ce
chilet là quelque part soit dans une
frerie ou soit urban outfit il trouvait
beau il l'achète a mis puis tu sais il y
a eu
un une grosse mode de gilet de ben tu
sais puis le Justin Bieber mettait des
gilets de métal puis tu sais c'est comme
C c'est comme devenu cool puis pour des
ex métalux c'est ça l'affaire c'est
c'est de là ça c'est ça mais c'est parce
que moi je suis pas une métaleuse je
porterais pas un chandil de blackbit
mais ton s pas moi c'est c'est ça que
j'allais faire comme distinction là
juste pour pour reprendre la balle où
est-ce que tu l'as laissé Dom la
distinction que j'allais faire c'est
Nirvana ok le gars qui t'écrit en disant
lol Nirvana c'est comme M tu genre
tues-tu si spécial que ça que tu genre
que toi Nirvana c'est ton ben à toi
genre que tout le monde écoutait Nirvana
tout le monde a djà entendu Nirvana
c'est un ben planétaire c'est sûr que
genre tu portes Nirvana tu sais c'est
quoi c'est comme OK moi quand je vois
mettons ça a été la grosse mode
justement au Forever 21 m pu en plus au
Simons même que des fois il donneent
même pas de redevance au ben pour les
les gilets qui vendent là fait que ça
c'est un autre problème en soi mais
d'avoir un gilet soit de comme Black
sabbat ou de motor headad mettons moi
Motorhead c'est c'est un Benand que
j'aime beaucoup j'ai un tattoo pour
Motorhead c'est un comme je m'y suis
vraiment attaché quand j'étais jeune
puis quand qu'on é secondaire c'était
pas ce qui était le plus cool porter des
gilettes Ben de métal tu sais ça n ça
nous mettait pas à table des Coes sauf
que là le monde qui sont à table des
cooles maintenant qui achète des gilets
Motorhead en sachant pas c'est quoi le
ben en ayant pas entendu Motorhead juste
parce qu'il est au Forever 21 alors que
moi c'était littéralement une identité
mais qu'est-ce que tuas vient chercher
est-ce que tu dis oh mon dieu j'aime
moins le ben tout d'un coup parce qu'il
y a quelqu'un qui aime pas le ben tu
sais metton moi là je te disais j'adore
l' cololoc je vois quelqu'un qui a un
chandail d'écol je vais dire ah
tuaimes-tu ce ben là aussi c'est un de
mes PRS il v dire non je sais pas c'est
quoi c'est sûr que ma réaction première
ce sera pas quel esprit de Plou je vais
me dire oh mon dieu ben là c'est trop
drôle que tu connaisses pas ça est-ce
que tu as envie que je t'en parle moi
c'est un sujet inépuisable tu sais dans
le sens où ça peut ouvrir une
conversation mais où est-ce que où
est-ce que le le ce que moi ce qui moi
viens me chercher c'est comme ok parce
que là c'est trendy c'est là que c'est
là que que vous embarquez dans patente
tu sais alors que quand ça l'était pas
cétait C N autres les métalux les MARG
au final on des Gets de métal mais
prendsles pour toi moi je portais des
salopettes avant que ça soit la mode on
riait de moi pour ça
finalement honnêtement je t'ai entends
parler tu as probablement raison ouais
je P y a juste je pense que la musique
peut-être moins maintenant maintenant je
pense que c'est idtiire quand même ou
exact c'est ça tu sais puis je pense que
maintenant le monde écoute plus de tout
puis genre c'est plus comme tu as le
droit d'écouter du punk puis du rap puis
tout en même temps puis quand qu'on
était jeune en tout cas c'était pas
vraiment ça c'était comme les
rapidentifia
comme les yo les poil mais tu sais tu
choisissais un peu comme ton ton ton
camp si on veut puis là ça faisait vra
partie de ton identité puis c'était très
justement c'était très identitaire puis
là on dirait que quand qu'on se fait
quand que quelqu'un porte ça c'est comme
si on se faisait un peu voler notre
approprier notre culture mais après
est-ce que tous les orticulteurs vont
m'écrire en me disant tu es pas une
jardinière pourquoi il y a des fleurs
sur ton gabinet tu sais c'est parce que
pour moi mon point c'est où ça s'arrête
tu sais je veux dire ce chandail làrê
écrire à quelqu'un c'est là ça s'arrête
c'est çarte ça s'arrête parce que
comment tu te sens par rapport à
quelqu'un qui porte un gelet de motorhe
tu peux faire ah genre tu peux te sentir
faire comme genre je trouve ça poche
d'écrire à personne c'est comme ça
t'appartient plus genre c'est là que ça
s'arrê la même façon que si j'étais venu
en leing aujourd'hui tu m'aurais pas dit
he tu pas une SP tu
fais nomme-moi trois exercices
si ce que je vais faire là c'est que je
vais m'acheter SEP chandailes de merch
d'arianeri un pour chaque jour la
semaine puis il y a plus personne qui va
me faire chier nom toutes les albums t
je vis P te chanter les tons de A à Z
exa combi de Ch tu as vu 14 tu vu fois
en show ben on s'est vu on s'est vu 4 C
fois dans des show d'Arian je pense
combien de fois tu penses tu l'as vu
Arian en CH oh j'ai eu le temps de la
voir avec des pupilles plus ou moins
grosses là fa quand même une coupe de
fois non mais honnêtement mettons sans
exagération
aucune une dizaine quand même ah oua je
connais son ça on s pas croiser à chaque
fois les fois tu tu es resté je suis
capable de dire à quelqu'un oh va faire
ça là tu vas voir quand quand fait band
parc à module C bout là c'est tellement
Hute je peux ouais mais c'est la
modulation sur ban de parc en
merci c'est quoi tu m' dit l'aut jour
dit votre version d' version
regéé é un peu réé votre dernière
version des l ouais ouais avec les
petites percussion av un petit boom Chac
Chac qui pas là mais tu sais c'était on
l'avait pas pensé régé mais maintenant
que tu le dis quelque chose de régé
mais ouais faut qu'on laisse aller mais
F de te voir sur au podcast ou dans les
show d'Arian c'est touj un plaisir de
grand plaisir les gars merci tellement
de m'avoir reçu je m'excuse je trouve
pas que j'ai eu beaucoup d'écoute
aujourd'hui mais je va faire mieux la
prochaine fois mais tu sa quoi je
pensais je pensais que tu avais dit j'ai
pas reçu beaucoup d'écout de votre part
je du début à la fin mais c'est quoi
juste fin làdessus parce que tu fais
partie des rares qui vient ici puis que
qui nous retourne les questions les gens
s'intéresse pas à vous vous trouvez non
mais tu sais parce que les gens je pense
pu c'est bien correct parce que on on on
le vend pas non plus comme gen et on
veut absolument parler puis tu sais dans
le fond c'est comme des discussions
entrevu tu sais pu le mond qui sont
habit de faire des entrevu je pense que
c'est normal puis mais c'est le fun avec
toi parce que c'est tout le temps un
échange ça va comme dans les deux sens
puis comme tu sais tu on peut tous
s'exprimer puis trouve que c'est le fun
puis vous êtes commeine dans ce que
j'aime d'elle c'est qu'elle s'intéresse
à moi mais bref dans le podcast je me
suis demandé jeis en train de trop
parler puis par avir assez d'écoute en
plus ça m' cé en début podcast je pas
t'avoir
briser je veux juste je juste avec ça
mais mais bref c'est agréable puis parce
que quelqu'un qui s'intéresse aux gens
ça c'est F vous m'intéressez merci
becoup merci bye